[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
with an average life span of over a
hundred years giant tortoises are easily
the oldest reptiles in the world and the
longest living vertebrae on record
there are many tortoises in modern times
known to be over a hundred and fifty
years as their name implies giant
tortoises are massive creatures some
Wayne as much as nine hundred pounds and
over four feet long only two main groups
are giant tortoises still exist
the famous Galapagos Island tortoises
and the Aldabra giant tortoise in the
Seychelles today giant tortoises are
among the most endangered animals in the
world but at one time they used to be
abundant unfortunately because they're
easy prey and they could survive a long
time on ships many of these were hunted
to extinction by sailors for food I
guess it was their idea of canned food
the oldest land animal in the world
today is a giant tortoise named Jonathan
who lives on the island of st. Helena in
2020 he celebrated his one hundred and
eighty eighth birthday and Jonathan
might be around for a while because at
least a couple of these easygoing
creatures have been documented to have
lived beyond 250 years did you know the
Bible says the lifespan of the first
humans was measured in centuries stay
with his friends we're going to learn
more
as amazing facts brings you this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions welcome friends if
you've got a Bible question lines are
open this is Bible answers live and
here's the phone number eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven and
the good chance getting your call on
tonight's program if you call in early
that rings a little bit you can either
wait someone will pick it up or call
back and our screeners will pick up your
call they basically just take your
information your name so that we can
find out where you're going with your
question eight hundred God says we're
also streaming right now on Facebook and
that's the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
and the amazing facts Facebook page and
you can give us a call with your
question I am Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross good evening friends and
pastor Doug let's start the program with
prayer dear father we thank you the
brave will open up your word and study
together this evening and Lord we ask
your blessing be were those who are
listening I know we have folks scattered
across the country and some even
listening online in other countries Lord
and as we open up your word we pray for
your spirit to guide us lead us into a
clearer and a fuller understanding of
the truths found in the Bible for we ask
this in Jesus name Amen amen oh pastor
day you open the program talking about
well one of my favorite reptiles is a
tortoise I like tortoises they should
beat other reptiles but they love a long
time the vegetarians and living on
lettuce leaves or flowers or whatever
they eat and some of them have quite the
personality yeah I just have a lot of
time to develop different personality
traits years ago not too many years ago
probably six or seven years ago Karen
and I were in Australia we went to the
Australia Zoo and some people remember
it was and I think while Steve Irwin was
still alive and they had a tortoise
there named Harriet who had actually
been brought to Australia or sent to
Australia by Darwin that was over 200
years in age and we were in the
Seychelles and we saw a number of them
there they were over a hundred years in
age and you know now they have them
you know this one Jonathan 188 this year
so it's pretty amazing and it just made
me think about those verses in the Bible
I remember when I first started reading
the Bible and keep in mind I came from
an atheistic background so when I read
in the Bible and Adam lived 930 years
and he died I said well what does that
mean kids
surely can't mean 900 years and then I'd
read and Benny has a son named Enoch and
the Seth lives eight hundred and seven
years and he has sons and daughters and
all the days of Seth were nine hundred
and twelve years and then you keep on
going down of course you get to
Methuselah he gets the record for 969
years and people often wonder well that
can't be serious you know that's got to
be symbolic or you just cut the number
in half do some math with it to figure
out what it's really talking about or
they misinterpreted the Hebrew numbers
or maybe it's an allegory well now you
know as you continue reading and study
in the Bible those ages were literal
people were living in centuries and a
few reasons you know that I mean if
you're gonna believe the Bible is as
you're reading from the time of Adam
down to the time of Noah they're their
lifespans are beginning to shorten
they're getting further away from the
tree of life then after the flood you
know they largely started there were
nothing or pretty much nothing but a
vegetarian diet before the flood other
than when they sacrificed after the
flood all the vegetation being destroyed
they ended up eating more and more of
the clean animals which is why Noah took
the clean animals on the ark by sevens
and then you quickly see a lifespan of
man being shortened and it's going from
you nine hundred to eight seven six five
four you look at the the father of
Abraham over two hundred years and
Abraham one hundred and seventy-five
years Isaac one hundred and eighty
hundred and forty-seven for Jacob and it
it starts working its way down and then
you eventually get to where David says
in Psalms and this is in Psalms
ninety-first ten
the days of our years are three scores
who are in the Bible's twenty-three
scoring ten that would be seventy and if
by reason of strength they be fourscore
yet there is strength labor sorrow for
too soon cut off interesting 3,000 years
ago David kind of pegged what the
average lifespan is today now during the
dark ages the lifespan of man went way
down and in some continents I think in
an African right now I'm trying to
remember which country it is they've got
the shortest life span in the world it's
like 45 because of disease and war and
terrible conditions and then you go to I
think it's Japan is the highest life
expectancy and it's you know maybe 85 so
things have gone up quite a bit since
the Middle Ages where the lifespans were
shortened but we're never gonna get
beyond that threescore and ten until
Jesus comes back and I saw study and
maybe I'm belaboring this amazing fact
too long but I saw a study where
scientists they've talked about
everything they could do if if they did
everything they could possibly do to
strengthen and lengthen a person's life
they really said that the the mileage
that the average human is going to get
now with the very best genetics and the
very best medicine is about a hundred
and eight years of age I said after that
everything just falls apart mm-hmm and
so there was something in the tree of
life that we just don't have anymore and
you know I'm hoping that we'll get to
eat from that tree again you know pass
today talking about the tree of life it
is interesting genesis chapter 3 verse
22 this is after Adam and Eve sinned God
is speaking he says behold man has
become like one of us to know good and
evil now lest he put forth his hand and
take also the tree of life eat and live
forever therefore the Lord God sent him
out of the Garden of Eden so there was
something about this tree of life that
perpetuated the life of mankind of
course even after being sent out of the
Garden of Eden like you mentioned Adam
lived 930
then of course we have the drop-off that
takes place but I guess many people are
wondering does that tree of life still
exist and if so where is it yes
you know before god destroyed the world
with a flood evidently he took the
garden up to heaven and people might be
shocked by that but if God can bring the
New Jerusalem down he can take the
Garden of Eden up and you read in
Revelation that the Tree of Life is in
the middle of the paradise of God and so
he is going to restore that garden to
the world when he creates a new heaven
and a new earth and you can read about
that in Revelation most important thing
we want people to know how they can live
much longer like forever and we've got a
free offer that talks about how to live
forever in the City of God the book is
entitled heaven is that for real
and as we mentioned the Tree of Life we
understand from the Bible is in heaven
in the paradise of garden and we want to
be there so we'd be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the game
just ask for the book it's one that we
don't offer too often but it's just a
real encouragement it's called heaven is
it for real and the number to call for
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again asked for
the book called heaven is it for real if
you have a Bible question a phone line
here to the studio it's 800 four six
three seven two nine seven eight hundred
four 63 72 97 pastor Doug we can look at
the phone lines we have quite a few
callers who are waiting first call is
asking about something related to Daniel
Aaron Aaron Aaron is calling hi welcome
I speak with you I had a question in
regard to the 70th week of the annual
because I grew up in dispensationalism
the base basically call it make it so
I'm used to the whole pre-trib thing
right so I was wondering how the week
broke up because I read a book that was
that explained the first half of it all
on the fatal wound and all that but it's
like after that that I'm a little bit
confused by all right Aaron is asking a
question about a prophecy one of the
greatest if not the greatest prophecies
in the Bible that talks about the coming
of the Messiah that's found in Daniel
chapter 9 now we're probably not gonna
be able to break it all
in great detail but very quickly it's 70
weeks are determined this is Daniel 9:24
70 weeks are determined upon your people
upon the holy city to finish the
transgression to make an end of sins to
make reconciliation for iniquity to
bring in everlasting righteousness to
seal up the vision in the prophecy and
to anoint the most holy
so this vision says if a conclusion of
that to anoint that's - that's word
Messiah or the word Cristo the most holy
the Messiah would be anointed and then
he gives the time 70 weeks that 170
weeks is seventy times seven that's a
day in prophecy is a year seven times
seven is forty-nine seventy times seven
is 490 that's 490 years and he says that
the going the starting point is from the
commandment to restore and build
Jerusalem you find that given an Ezra
chapter seven it's 457 BC given by
artaxerxes from that time until the
Messiah would be anointed it said there
would be seven weeks and threescore and
two weeks and you can read that in verse
25 so seven weeks is seven times 7 49
threescore in two weeks
that all adds up to 69 weeks or 483
years from 457 when the command was
given to restore build Jerusalem unto
the baptism or anointing of Jesus in AD
27 was exactly 483 years then it said
the Messiah would confirm the covenant
with many that means his people for one
week for seven years
Jesus covenant was confirmed especially
to the Jewish nation three years he did
it in person then it says in the midst
of this last seven years he in the midst
of seven is three and a half he makes
the sacrifice ceased Jesus dies in the
cross the veil is rent in the temple
this purpose for the sacrificial system
ceases then for another three and a half
years the disciples only preach to the
Jewish nation until the stoning of
Stephen now III know that went by pretty
quick what's the lesson that we have on
pastor oi do you have a study guide it's
called right on time and it's probably
one of the most fascinating time
prophecies that you can find in the
Bible talking about Daniel chapter 9
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who asks again just ask to the study
guide it's called right on time and the
phone line is eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line after the study
guide right on time and you'll be able
to learn about the 70 week prophecy of
Daniel chapter nine even you'll learn
about a longer time period finally
Daniel 8:14 we called in two thousand
three hundred year prophecy so thanks
for your call Aaron next call of the
behaved is listening from North Carolina
we've got recent recent welcome to the
program and I believe it's
self-explanatory
Galatians 5:21 and Galatians 5:21 envy
murders drunkenness revellings and the
like of which I tell you before us I've
also told you in time past that those
who do such things will not inherit the
kingdom of God and you should also read
verse 26 and let us not be desirous of
vain glory provoking one another envying
one another well Jesus actually said to
Pontius Pilate when he's being tried he
said the one that handed me over to you
has the greater sin in other words
Pilate was just trying to you know do
the job of governor and put down an
insurrection but Judas and the religious
leaders that betrayed their own Messiah
they had the greater sin because they
knew Jesus was innocent and it was a
kangaroo court so do the soldiers yeah
they had a lesser sin in fact one of the
Centurions guarding the cross he said
surely this was the son of God he might
have been converted on the spot and but
it was certainly sin it's as they also
who pierced him will be judged
okay thanks a lot good question thank
you reason next photo that we have is
chase listening from Houston Texas chase
welcome to the program good evening
pastor specialer and Russ I'm glad to be
on the show thanks for having me well
glad you called in so my question is
concerning the the ceilings that
happened in Ephesians 1:13 and
revelation 7:3 and
the sealing that happens in Ephesians
1:13 is a feeling that seems to happen
in regards to our response and belief in
the gospel and so I'm trying to get a
better understanding of that feeling and
then also the people that are alive at
the time of revelation 7:3 why would it
be necessary for them to be resealed or
sealed a second time all right thank you
good question now of course revelation
is telling us that just before Jesus
comes everybody is on one side or the
other they're sort of compelled to
polarize in one of two directions and
one group has the mark of the beast in
their right hand or their forehead the
other group has the seal of God and it
says their father's name in their
forehead I mean the forehead in
Revelation is it's a symbolic about who
you are what who you worship you go to
revelation 17 it says that woman Babel
and as a paragraph in her forehead and
in the hand and in the forehead is
talking about in your actions or in your
thoughts and worship and those who have
the seal of God of course have the Holy
Spirit but it says in Isaiah chapter 8
verse 16 bind up the testimony seal the
law among my disciples Moses said when
before he died in Deuteronomy he said
these words I command you today he had
just given him the Ten Commandments
shall be in your heart you shall bind
them for a sign upon your hand they will
be as frontlets between your eyes and
the hebrew way that's the hebrew way of
basically seeing in your forehead
and so we're to have the law of God in
our hands and in our hearts matter of
fact Moses said these words shall be in
your heart and so and in the law of God
there is one commandment in particular
that has all the components of a seal
now don't we have a lesson that talks
about what the seal of God is that we
could send to chase absolutely we've got
actually two lessons we'd recommend the
one is talking about the law of God and
it's called written in stone and then we
have another study guide that's just
called the mark of the beast and it'll
talk about the seal of God versus the
mark of the beast of course the key
issue passed today in Revelation deals
with worship who do you worship God or
do we worship God or do we worship the
beast power and so that's the important
theme and we'll be happy to send these
lessons to anyone who calls and asks and
again the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can ask for those
lessons is talking about the mark of the
beast or written in stone talking about
the law of God and in particular the
fourth commandment that we understand to
have the marks of a seal so thank you
for your call chase next one of the
behalf is Pam listening from Oregon Pam
welcome to the program I passed her dad
pastor rod thanks for calling the engine
is in Isaiah 65 20 can you explain that
to me
alright we'll do our best go on there
right now Isaiah 65 20 sounds familiar
and maybe I can read it while you get
the pastor I guess ahead no Michelle an
infant from there lived but a few days
nor an old man who has not fulfilled
these days for the child shall die a
hundred years old but the sinner being a
hundred years old shall be accursed
and so in Isaiah 65 it's talking about
heaven and people read this they
naturally think what do you mean a child
will die hundred years old now that's
actually a great argument for our
opening fact a child a hundred where
would you see a child a hundred well if
people live a thousand a child a hundred
would make sense but it's simply saying
here that a child doesn't even cease to
be a child
until it was a hundred the word die
there is probably not a good translation
or that word can be translated cease
I've looked it up several times just to
double-check that I was saying that
right and so it's basically saying it a
child doesn't even cease to be a child
until it's a hundred and you will not
find in that city an old man who has not
fulfilled his days but a sinner being a
hundred years old she'll be a curse
meaning even after a hundred years go by
the sinner is accursed
so no children dying in heaven there's
no death the Bible says in Revelation no
crying no pain no sorrow and it's just
basically saying that child will not
cease to be a child until it's a hundred
does that help him yeah it helps a
little bit I had a quick question
another one was on earth we were the
same height as a common man but in great
controversy it beats she speaks about
Jesus being taller than Adam can you
explain that to me
yeah yeah well you know in the beginning
not only did men live much longer but
they were evidently much bigger much
taller and you know man was made lofty
and through the ages because of sin man
has become stunted now in the
resurrection you know Christ is going to
be the size of the original perfect man
his man was made in His image he'll be
the size of a demur probably a little
bigger and the rest of us it says in
Malachi chapter 4 they shall go forth
and grow up as calves of the stall so
even in our resurrected form were
probably going to grow into the original
ideal of what God had in mind for from
man in the beginning before the
degeneration of sin all right well thank
you for your cold pam again that book
that we mentioned at the beginning of
the program heaven isn't for real i
think you'll enjoy reading that as well
number is 883 five six seven four seven
that is our resource phone line we've
got Mike listening in Massachusetts Mike
welcome to the program good evening
I guess Christian character it has
always been my understanding or at least
how I interpret or what people have told
me about we need to have the character
of Christ to get into heaven
so while we're here on earth we're you
know developing our character to make it
to that benchmark of Christ's character
which were sinful and I never will be
perfect here on earth so what does it
mean Christian character and do we have
to have be perfect before Christ comes
well we need to be perfectly committed
and I I think that's that's the key you
know this is one of the big questions
people ask they say well you know I want
to follow Christ but it seems like I
always fall short and you can't talk to
an honest Christian anywhere in the
world if you ask them do you feel like
you're good enough even the Apostle Paul
he said you know I do not count myself
to have apprehended and I says that one
place another place he says that I think
he says I neither am i perfect I think
he actually uses the word perfect but
the question is we need to have faith
that will be like the faith of the
people that are mentioned in Hebrews 11
we need to have the kind of faith that
Daniel had when he said I'd rather died
and then deny God or Shadrach Meshach
and Abednego I would rather die and go
to the furnace then deny God and bow
down to an idol they had a perfect trust
in God and it didn't mean that they were
never tempted or that they never fell I
probably did not mean that they you know
never took one bite too much of dessert
because you know by that standard you
wonder who is gonna be who's gonna feel
like they qualify so but we do need to
be perfectly committed we need to have
that perfect love and if you're a child
and you're 12 years old and you love
Jesus and you make up your mind to
surrender your life to Jesus and even
though you may still have childish ways
as as Jesus put it to Peter
if that child dies and there you know
they're having their devotions and
they're seeking after Christ you're
gonna see them in the kingdom it's the
attitude of rebelling you know I think
of an example of that pastor day um you
got Shadrach Meshach and Abednego on the
plain of Dura in the days of
Nebuchadnezzar they were willing to go
to the fiery furnace then knowingly
disobey one of God's commandments well
at the end of time the Bible speaks of
another image that's set up by the beast
power and God's people like Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego choose to be loyal
to God they choose to have that perfect
trust and commitment where they are
willing to lay down their life now
because that's not something we can do
in and of ourselves it is the working of
the Holy Spirit it is the sealing work
that the Spirit does for those who are
seeking it we do need to ask for the
Holy Spirit because without God we can
do nothing as the Bible says yeah and he
just really wants us to be wholly
committed to him Mike and you know I've
actually got a sermon online I think
you'll enjoy and it's how how perfect
should a Christian be or you might even
type in the perfect Christian Doug
Batchelor just YouTube it and I think
you'll find it where I talk about this
exact question because I think everyone
wonders and will I ever be good enough
how good do I need to be Jesus does not
want us to live our lives in fear with
no assurance and then he also doesn't
want us to be reckless about sin and so
between those two I think a Christian
can have faith in confidence
well we work out our salvation with fear
and trembling you've got that balance
thank you thanks Mike we've got Sam
you're listening in Wisconsin Samuel
welcome to the program we have just a
minute before we take our break peace to
you brothers thanks Colin about Jeremiah
8:1 and acts 2:29 referring to the tombs
of the kings where the burial of the
Israeli kings are and I understand
there's an Israeli archaeologist that is
close to finding this in prophecy its
wondrous pastor all right so you said
Jeremiah 8:1 at that time that she'll
bring out the bones of the kings of
Judah
and the bones of its princess and the
bones of the priests and the bones of
the prophets out of the graves and
spread them before the Sun at noon and
the other verse you gave me was Acts
chapter 2 verse 29 and that's where it's
talking about the tomb of David who was
with us even unto this day right where
there's a dig going on called this let
the stone speak the Lord is a wonderful
pastor to let us know of his existence
yeah if Pastor Ross and I were actually
in Israel I guess it's been about a year
and a half ago now time flies it seems
like it was just a few months ago and we
were at the archaeological dig in the
old city of David and we went to the
location of this the tomb the
sarcophagus or the Sepulcher of David
that is in Jerusalem to this day now
when it talks about the the burial of
the Kings a lot of the Kings were buried
in some of the valleys and so different
Kings were buried in different places
like I know King Isaiah cuz he had
leprosy he was not buried in the regular
city of the Kings didn't mean to cut you
off like that Samuel we are we're right
up against our mid time break we're not
going to don't go anywhere France we're
gonna be back in just a minute with more
questions
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other binders giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 oh we're so we're
streaming from Northern California and
it's at amazing facts Facebook page or
the Doug Batchelor Facebook page and we
are gonna go back to the phones I'm Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and our
next one that we have is Stan listening
from New Mexico Stan welcome to the
program thank you thank you for calling
and your question my question is Christ
who lived a sinless life became sin for
us such that God had to turn his face
away
prior to Christ's death so did Christ
die the second death now he said had
said before that he had the power to lay
down his life and he had the power to
take it up again
yes so his divinity as I see it did not
die but did his humanity die the second
death or can I answer I'm gonna try and
answer your question with a question
Stan so the penalty for sin is it the
first death or the second death second
did Jesus pay our penalty yeah then he
must have faced the grave the same way
the lost person faces the second death
so obviously Jesus
is not still dead because the second if
there's no resurrection from that but
the experience of Christ when he went to
the grave he felt the separation from
God that the doomed sinner feels
following the judgment of the second
death that feeling of that of darkness
and eternal separation now you then
raise another question and I'm not sure
that I can answer it because it's
something of a mystery about did Jesus
divinity die well Christ you know he
said I lay down my life and I take it up
again if Jesus was dead was he conscious
in death and if he wasn't conscious in
death and how could he raise himself up
well I think Christ being the word the
very power of the word was it raised him
up or it was through the glory of the
father so that's something of a mystery
but I think we've got to be careful to
stick to the text that says Jesus died
and so you know Jesus really didn't die
he said how could God die well good
thing that God the Father was still
there listen but he paid the penalty for
our sins and he was raised and we
started you know I think we start
delving on holy ground when we try to
understand the divinity and what
happened there with the death of Christ
I certainly don't have the exact answers
on that but I'm just gonna stick with
what the Bible says thank you so much
Stan good question the next one of the
we have is calling from Oregon
we got ad on the phone and walk with the
program well thank you and thank you for
taking my call and god bless you for
what you guys are doing appreciated
thanks
so my question and I've been asked this
many times and I don't honey % know how
to answer it but when Christ was here on
earth it says that he ate fish and if we
are supposed to be like Christ as
Christians and we're supposed to have a
vegetarian diet or vegan as it is it
okay for us to eat fish if Christ ate
fish and do we know if he ate any other
flesh
food well here yeah when Jesus came down
and he met with Abraham it says that
they wouldn't they prepared the fatted
calf and it sounds like they ate
together you know Sarah went and our
Abraham's will slaughter the fatted calf
and Sarah made bread and they talked to
Jesus in these two angels this is that
pre incarnation of Christ when he met
with Abraham before Sodom and Gomorrah
were destroyed
Fairey what chapter that is is that like
eighteen of Genesis and I forget anyway
so yeah there he's eating meat and so
yeah and I think what ad is talking
about here is course in heaven the ideal
is that man should you know they're not
going to kill animals and eat them in
heaven and it it's just uh not only a
Bible fact that in the Garden of Eden
the original diet for man was a
vegetarian diet and in heaven it'll be a
vegetarian diet E and it's a health fact
that the vegetarians do have less
disease so much disease is connected
with you know animal products and
cholesterol and that is it a sin you
know Jesus ate fish and well I think
there's a lot of fish eaters are going
to heaven there's a lot of people that
eat meat that are gonna go to heaven
there are gonna be people who ate pork
even though the Bible says you shouldn't
eat pork that are going to heaven
probably cuz they didn't know any better
and you know God winks at our times of
ignorance sin is knowing to do good and
not doing it now for me because you know
I what I've known and I personally been
a vegetarian for boy over 40 years now
that he I would really feel like I'd
backslidden if I went out and got a
hamburger and you know I feel pretty
good for my age and I think that some of
it is because of that so I wouldn't say
well because Jesus wore sandals do we
have to wear sandals well Jesus lived
with people back then he probably ate
lamb at the Passover during the Passover
meal and that certainly was not a sin
but you know as time goes by
we get closer to the second coming I
think we're preparing for eternity the
standards of the church don't go down
they go up I think just from a practical
perspective pastor they're probably the
fish that Jesus ate all you
the lamb that he ate was probably a lot
more raised in an environment that was a
lot more no mercury no hormones yeah
less pollution less hormones I mean they
weren't raised in factories so you know
probably overall it was healthy and and
even today we hear about different
diseases that have come as a result of
you know maybe the confinement of cattle
you have the mad cow disease that kind
of went around of course we're dealing
with this coronavirus people have traced
it back to animals so I think if ever
there was a time for us to be careful it
won't be eat now more than ever it would
be with what's happening yeah absolutely
thank you ad hope that helps a little
preview and we do have that lesson on
God's free health plan we'd be happy to
send you a copy yes if you'd like to
receive it the number to call is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and again just ask for that study god
it's called God's free health plan and
we'll send it out to anyone who calls
and asks we've got Nina listening from
Puerto Rico Nina welcome to the program
all right how are you great thank you
for calling hey thanks for getting my
call I have a friend she I'm not gonna
say the denomination but she stated that
she believes that the old only ones that
are gonna be saved to the 144,000 and
that she's not gonna go to heaven
because she doesn't believe she will be
part of that how can I answer that to
her well thanks I'm glad you asked that
question we'll also be sending you a
book or if you're in Puerto Rico you may
get it quicker if you download it on who
are the hundred and forty-four thousand
you can share with her but revelation
doesn't say that only a hundred and
forty-four thousand are going to be
saved you can encourage her that I
believe it's in Chapter 7 verse 9 pastor
Ross where it says that there's a great
multitude that no man can number that is
also going to be saved and the hundred
and forty-four thousand in the last days
are doing a special work just like Jesus
had twelve apostles
during the first coming that prepared
the lost house of Israel for being ready
in the second coming he's going to have
twelve times twelve thousand last day
apostles they are not the only ones are
saved
they've got a special
work of leadership the number 12 through
the Bible whether it's the 12 judges of
the 12 princess of Israel whether Twelve
Apostles they were in leadership
positions in the last days he's gonna
have a hundred and forty-four thousand
spirit filled leaders that are going to
help do what the Apostles did in
bringing about a great revival in which
a great multitude is saved that no man
can number so encourage your friend you
know I did the math once and if there's
like 8 billion people in the world and
only a hundred and forty-four thousand
are saved that would mean your chances
of being saved or one in 50,000 and
while that's better than the lottery it
would discourage someone so people need
to know that's not what the Bible is
teaching it's not saying they're only
going to be 144,000 saved and again you
mention pastor that the book that deals
with that and it's available online for
free if you just go to the amazing facts
website to our free library and it's
called 144,000 and it just looked that
up and all the Bible references are
there and it is a great read great study
thank you for your call Nina we've got
Robert listening from Washington Robert
welcome to the program
oh hey Pastor Austin pastor bachelor hi
thanks for calling yeah I missed last
week I mean I just the time ran out kind
of thing we'll forgive you right now yep
so my question was regarding any queezy
a student at verse that we know quite
quite well about the spirit returning to
God and one denomination that I like to
work with believes you know that we were
in heaven before we were born and so
they like they like this verse to store
does Ecclesiastes 12:7 mean that we were
alive we were before we were before we
were born if we if we were to return to
God yeah good question and yeah there
are there are some Christians out there
that believe that humans were actually
intelligent spirits before they became
humans on earth and some and they came
down and have
these bodies you know that's almost like
reincarnation because I used to believe
in reincarnation I always thought I
don't understand it what good is
reincarnation if I don't remember my
former life and I can't learn from it so
it's saying that you continue to keep
coming back as something if you have no
prior memory of your other life that
other life does you no good at all it's
just like starting all over anyway so
but when it says the spirit returns to
God it's not talking about a conscious
being is returning to God the word their
spirit in Hebrew is roll-off you almost
got a growling your throat to say it
roll off and it means breath and it's
the same word you find in Genesis where
it says God breathed into atoms and
nostrils the breath of life it is the
essence the power of life it is not a
conscious being it is the power of life
that God gives his creatures in an
Ecclesiastes 12 it's not just talking
about men it's talking about animals you
notice it doesn't say the good returned
to God it's the good the bad every
creature that dies when they died their
bodies decompose and turn to dust the
spirit of life returns to God who gave
it
and we do have a study guide that talks
about this very subject it's called are
the dead really dead and of course we'll
be happy to send this for free to anyone
who calls the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and you can ask for
that study guide called are the dead
really dead and we also have a website
that amazing facts is put together it's
got a lot of great resources there's
some video content and some sermons
there it's called death truth calm just
death truth calm and you can learn more
about what the Bible says happens to
people when they die and I think you'll
find that encouraging when you take a
study and look at what the Bible says
thanks you're Col Robert we've got
sherry listening from 1:10 eyes sherry
welcome to the program
hi there how are you guys hope things
are well for you we're doing good thank
you for calling that's good it's kind of
a can I find it a confusing question um
quite some time many years ago I read
about the four winds
mm-hmm but then and I don't remember it
all but is there also four corners left
the world
if that makes any sense I I know
live a vaguely about the four winds
hopefully you can help me refresh my
memory with everything but is there also
something about the four corners yes the
world or you find four corners mentioned
how 63 times in the Bible you can read
like in Isaiah 11 12
he'll gather together the dispersed of
Judah from the four corners of the earth
Ezekiel seven to the end is come upon
the four corners of the land Ezekiel 43
verse 16 well that's awfully talking
about a building there four corners so
four corners typically is talking about
the four corners of the compass north
south east west those guidelines are
very ancient and when talks about the
four winds that's talking about winds
used to come from the Northeast to come
from the south east and the west and you
know now sailors kind of divided up they
say north northeast northeast south
southwest I mean so we divide up the
compass winds that way but it's a figure
of speech they use talking about
something that was universal so when it
says Jesus will send His angels and they
will gather together his elect from the
four corners of the earth
that means from all over the world north
south east west he's going to gather
them all not just in Israel and when it
talks about God's angels are holding
back the four winds of strife that's
times of trouble and the reason it's
four means it's a universal problem like
right now we are having four winds that
are blowing in the world the pandemic is
causing universal economic and health
issues and social issues too evidently
so it's it's a Four Winds problem it's a
universal problem
does that help you a little bit sherry
oh yes it does I thank you very much I
was just going to say some
than when you mentioned it's not just
about Israel now my quick question there
is isn't Israel God's people
yeah well the the Lord chose the
children of Israel to be the guardians
of the Oracles of truth and you know
Jesus said salvation is of the Jews in
John chapter four and Paul tells us that
unto Israel were committed the Oracles
and that that does not mean when you say
a people of God God is no respecter
persons God equally loves and wants to
save everybody and again the Bible tells
us that God has made of one blood all
nations of the world and even the Lord
said back in the Old Testament he told
Israel I did not choose you because
you're better or more godly than anyone
else then he said in fact you're a
stubborn and a stiff-necked people so I
chose you to show my glory in my
salvation so they were chosen as his
people to display his character and
glory to the world and really to be the
guardians of the word the Bible was all
recorded and guarded by the children of
Israel but now the gospel is going to
the four corners of the earth so those
two questions tied together Thank You
sherry appreciate that and we do have a
book on spiritual Israel we can yes the
number to call for that it is just eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again the book is called
spiritual Israel he talks not about
ancient Israel that you read about in
the Old Testament but it also talks
about two spiritually throughout how
that the believing in Christ becomes
part of Abraham's seed heirs according
to the promise so take a look at that
it's called spiritual Israel next caller
that we have is Marcus listening in New
Jersey Marcus you're on the air hello
after all that's a bachelor I bring you
greetings from the East Coast how are
you guys doing good thank you and your
question tonight so my question is about
baptism and I've been struggling with
this for the past three weeks and acts
2:38 Peter says repent and be baptized
every one of you
in the name of Jesus Christ for the
forgiveness of your sins you will
receive a gift of the Holy Spirit and so
my question is is baptism for the
remission of sins now I would say that
scholars point to the Greek phrase for
the remission of sins as modifying the
two preceding Burke's repent and be
baptized in the early church also seems
a time to talk and besides baptism as
Christ I commanded them as necessary for
attaining salvation and of course you
remember jesus' conversation with
Nicodemus unless one is born of water
and the spirit he cannot enter the
kingdom of God and then finally the
doctrine of so lofty day by faith alone
seemed very much intact and the doctrine
in the theology in the leadership within
the early church as evidenced in Paul's
letters however it also feels like that
was lost obviously between the 538 okay
well you're getting pretty deep here
let's just this is summarize it into a
question so you want to know just it
does is it necessary to be baptized to
have your sins washed away yes okay let
me read a verse for you in Acts chapter
Ananias says to Paul and verse acts
22:16 sorry acts 22:16 now why are you
waiting
arise and be baptized and wash away your
sins calling on the name of the Lord now
the water does not wash away our sins
but baptism is as important to a
Christian as a wedding is to a marriage
if a person says can I have a wife
without a wedding well you can have a
common-law wife but that's usually not
the way it's done you usually don't get
those rights and privileges unless you
go through the Covenant baptism is a
public covenant through which you get
very real benefit when you publicly
testify your acceptance of the Lord you
go through the ceremony of baptism that
symbolizes the washing away of your sin
it's something h2o it's the faith that
washes away the sin but Christ commands
us to do it and so it's a very important
ceremony last words of Christ were or go
teach baptize first thing Jesus does
when he begins his ministry he is
baptized and he is our example and the
Apostles you know they said repent and
be baptized and so going through that
commitment that ceremony the Holy Spirit
often came on a person
after that so if that's what you're
saying we would agree with you we have a
free study guide we'll send you on
baptism is it necessary it's actually
the book that's one of that's right I'm
just looking at past that I get some
great study talking about the subject of
baptism if you'd like to receive the
book on baptism it's called baptism is
very necessary the number to call for
that he's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again just ask
for the book called baptism is it really
necessary our next call that we have is
uh Sylvia listening from Michigan Sylvia
welcome to the program thank you for
taking my call yeah and my question is
about wine in the Bible in the Old
Testament it's talking about not
touching the wine when it's red and
moving I'm assuming that's alcoholic the
wedding he made wine and then Jesus made
mine and then in Timothy when Paul said
for Timothy take some wine purse
stomachs sake and I have I tried when I
talk to people about it that there's a
difference one is like grape juice and
one is alcoholic it's fermented young
yeah and I I didn't know a good way to
explain it to them and tell you the
truth I get the same reaction from lost
people and saved people I can't it's
amazing to me that they don't understand
well good question I yeah I know it's
unfortunate because there's nothing good
that comes from alcohol in any culture
and that verse pastor Ross where it says
as the new wine is in the cluster it's
in Isaiah as it's 60 or 65 or 66 I think
and he says do not destroy it for
there's a blessing in it sixty-five
eight Isaiah 65 eight so if you look at
Isaiah 65 eight Sylvia you're gonna see
that it says as the new wine is in the
cluster now if it's in the cluster it's
clearly not fermented I eat grapes
this morning and they're not I guess it
was yesterday remember what I had today
but I
anyway grapes they're they're not
fermented they're not going to get you
drunk but they call it wine
and Jesus said his doctrine is a new
wine new wine was unfermented you don't
put new wine or grape juice in old wine
skins or as it ferments they expand and
it rips him it bursts them and so
there's the word wine is used for both
new in the new in the Old Testament for
both fermented and unfermented it's the
only word they did not use the word
grape juice anywhere in the Bible God
never recommends drinking the fermented
juice because it's a symbol of
decomposition and corruption for the
Passover Christ told the disciples I
will not drink this cup until I drink it
with you again new in the father's
kingdom they drank unfermented wine and
unleavened bread is what they ate symbol
of the body and the blood of Jesus that
were pure most of the misery in our
society comes from alcohol Noah drinks
alcohol and stumbles around naked lot
drinks alcohol and sleeps with his
daughters David tries to get Uriah drunk
so he will go against his conscience and
so and the Bible says wine is a mocker
strong drink is raging Jesus turned the
water into fresh new wine what you'd
call unfermented grape juice they said
you've you've got the best wine you save
the best wine where did you get this
they could get fermented wine all year
long you can keep it for years when it's
fermented finding new wine was only
during the harvest and so yeah alcohol
bad news you know we do have a book
talking about alcohol in the Bible it's
called alcohol and the Christian and
looks at these different Bible verses
we'll be able to send that to anyone who
asks the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can ask for the book
called alcohol and the Christian we have
got Jeremy that is calling from West
Virginia Jeremy walked to the program
hey thank you well we've got about a
minute and a half so what can we do okay
I was I was real curious you know in the
beginning of the Bible it talks about
how God created everything in seven days
and I was in fact my question about two
questions and one first is is one day
creation of him is that like that's
24-hour period is us or like work took
him to do them one day would be five
thousand years for us no I believe one
day was a literal 24-hour period Jeremy
because it tells us that the evening in
the morning were the first day and God
makes the vegetation on the third day
but he doesn't make the Sun Moon and
stars until the fourth day if those days
were allegories of thousands of years or
hundreds of years all the plants would
have died so God made the world in six
days and it says in several places in
the Bible in six days he created the
heavens and the earth and it means days
God can do it in days it's small thing
for him he could have done it in one day
and of course we have the week cycle
even today and the week traces its
origin all the way back to creation we
God created the earth in six days you
rested on the seventh day and we know
that to be literal 24 hours the turning
of the earth as it rotates on its axis
so yeah if we're gonna take what the
Bible says we're gonna have to take it
as literal 24 hours amen
you don't pastor Ross looking at the
clock I see waiting in line right it
we've got a Richard and Tony and Ashton
and Bruce and Sasha and I'm sorry I
don't think we're gonna get to your
calls tonight and be able to do them
justice we had wonderful turnout if
callers tonight hey friends you can
continue to listen to Bible answers live
because we've got a bunch of programs
archived about twenty years worth and
there's so much more amazing facts
offers a lot of the free offers we
mentioned you can find at our website
amazing facts dot o-r-g if you've been
blessed and if the spirits touch you
we're a hundred percent supported by you
go to the website click donate to help
keep us on the air god bless talk to you
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California terror attacks
natural disasters political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation and the day of the
Lord but did you know the Bible speaks
about another day of the Lord just
before the great Judgment Day amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
Sabbath that was meant to forever be a
time of restoration for every human
being a day the entire world is largely
forgotten you'll be surprised to learn
how this special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called
the last day of prophecy to order call
800 538 7 to 75 or visit a book store
calm written by the hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 877-709-7899
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]